you've lived in LA for how long I don't
live in LA I've never lived in LA well
being you've worked here though I've
worked in that's what I'm sorry yeah
you're moving here Am I yeah hey thanks
for helping out Jeff I just want her to
move here oh yeah thinking he's that
worried if you were watching backstage
you know he's not drinking anything so
you don't know I know you don't live
here but you've you've been in LA you've
worked here so you have lived here
temporarily how's that yes you've lived
in a rental apartment or a hotel yeah
exactly I have so I know a little bit
about life in LA compared to London like
the sunshine for example is very
pleasant but you had never seen it
before
what is this fiery orb in the sky yeah
this mandi deficient but someone said to
me the difference between say New York
where I'd spent time and New York and LA
is that New Yorkers have a very rude way
of being polite and LA has a very polite
way of being rude I think that's that's
very smart
that's good actually that's really good
oh my god you're amazing I love you
you're incredible you're fantastic
I never heard from that person again I
didn't get the job so I was like by the
way think of the character you just did
would you like to hear from that person
again I would not want that person to
contact me under any circumstances my
only American character seems to be able
to do I apologize
what securities no she's her name's
Tiffany
I don't ever want to meet Tiffany go
back to come date I've been looking at
the back of your head for five minutes
right now while you talk to a guy at the
next restaurant booth who's busy eating
doughnuts and smoking sativa
I don't smoke city by smoke indica don't
let him hijack you I'm in the middle of
a domestic yeah kind of so let's talk
about I want to talk about Howards End
Howards End
is the project that you're here to talk
about and what I love about it of course
this takes place turn-of-the-century
and it's a period drama but what I love
about it is that you guys have clearly
made an effort to make the acting feel
natural not natural bottom that's not
what not up its own bottom as we say in
the UK Oh like we didn't want to make it
feel like stiff there was this kind of
way yeah well yes yes way yes something
was up your bottom you would become
stiff you like that yeah you'd be stiff
you'd be like what and then maybe you'd
be like hey you know but naturally
yupi initially there'd be a surprise and
a stiffening yes and then a realization
that this is where you were always meant
to be but what's nice is what's nice is
that you is that the director who wanted
to do that who was that he would say
sometimes she goes if anyone does para
drum acting I'm going to cut you off and
stop take so we go oh now what is to you
define period drama it's like good day
and and I can arch of an eyebrow in the
sip of a teen then looking wistfully out
of a window in a very beautiful
landscape yeah right and kind of like
people kind of and you have this I think
also because in inaudi in England the
photographs you had to remain still so
that the camera wasn't blurry in the
picture so as long as this preconception
that we thought that we were all like
this yeah time that we'd relate to each
other like that so we want to see the
opposite so Hattie sometimes would stop
us and go um that's that's not
interesting I don't believe you right
and you'd go oh okay and then relax a
little bit and then have a good time
overdue Tiffany on that show she might
make an appearance
how would you sound I said good day to
you good sir you have the party
you